о.в.
у грунт Щиро вітаємо вас це програми У
фокусі Європи
парламент І багато хто боїться суттєво
зміцнення популістських партій а також
Європейського парламенту розраховує
правляча партія право і справедливість і
з націоналістичними гаслами та
критичними лозунгами щодо Європейського
Союзу голова партії Качинський хоче
завоювати більшість голосів
Європейським Союзом партії не шкода
опозиційні Альянсу площі прагне зміни
цілком має на це шанси в
в
останні приготування аджарські та
музикантів польської Блек метал групи
бегемот у Варшаві в
а незадовго до початку свого нового
європейського туру вони грають три
концерти у Польщі її нелегко адже
царській провокує
[музика]
так і не лише музики адамдар відноситься
до найбільш політичних художників Польщі
що чинять опір праві націоналістичні
партії яка критикує Європу
й рішуче виступає проти актуально курсу
політиків які керують нашої країни уже
два роки адже вони заганяють на ізоляцію
[музика]
свої політичні позиції на
і тому хресті
це дратує більшість у Польщі де
католицька церква є надзвичайно
консервативною і підтримує
націоналістичний уряд
а депутат Домінік Торчинський справи
партії художників
я піду зброї він порушив закон
кримінальне право дуже чітке не можна
зачіпати жодна релігія не можна ображати
жодні релігійні почуття
зробив
перед парламентом у Варшаві такі
незвичні католицькі противник абортів з
плакат із написом розмножують
контрастом й навпаки адамдар та його
прихильники багато їх приходить сюди має
салон-перукарня для осередку у Варшаві а
також в інших великих ліберальних містах
країни музика Black Metal стиль життя
політика так він протестує проти право
націоналістичного часто обмеженого
істеблішменту
політична ситуація для мене комфортною
за допомогою юстиції ми не викликають у
поліцію на наші концерти проходять
служба безпеки щоб стежити за нами
перевіряти чи не повними якісь підривні
дії в
у дарский і бегемот не хочуть дозволити
себе цим залякати
найбільшими хеві-метал осередками тут у
салоні перукарні для співробітників
зокрема мова йде насамперед про відчуття
вільного життя в
[музика]
у фізичних поглядів і так ставали більш
зацікавленими в
[музика]
у адамдар зі своєю групою бегемот
продовжує грати музику і
А ти ми всі ін'єкцій Зараз ми хочемо
розповісти вам про долю одного чоловіка
що є особливою його країні він живе на
південному сході Туреччини
велику роль відіграють традиції та
консервативні цінності тому хто випадає
тут з існуючих вольових рішень
доводиться нелегко цього чоловіка звуть
разі сік він інтерсексуал людина
що живе життям яке інколи доводить його
до межі відчаю й
ти
найкраща зі спочиваю себе коли
залишається наодинці зі своїм стадом тут
зверху він нікому не повинен пояснювати
Чому він народився дівчинкою і називався
раніше разі з тут може бути просто таким
яким він є
я сама-сама извивается якими Інколи мені
подобається бути серед людей але дуже
часто Я хочу бути просто на самоті і
тоді мені знову всього забагато як воно
заспокоїтися і найкраще тут і
у разі живе у селі неподалік від
сирійського кордону одна турецька газета
назвала це місце проклятим Адже лише у
цьому селі живе більше 20
інтерсексуалізм людей без однозначної
статті таких як зараз вже 50 річної Азії
в нього немає чітко виражених зовнішніх
статевих органів тому він ще й до
сьогодні повинен носити по собі рожеве
посвідчення жінка при цьому ще дитиною
він усвідомлював що не хоче бути
дівчиною Я зараз в
у лісі на поверхні
одного разу коли побився з одним хлопцем
він потягнув мене за має довге волосся і
кинув на землю Після чого я побіг додому
і волосся відрізав я був сповнений
ненависті до себе свого оточення а через
посвідчення я ще й досі страждає в
а
усі віддаленій частині Туреччини все Що
прийнято одружуватися із родичами у дуже
бідно і між собою тому швидко
поширюється спадкові хвороби також і
інтерсексуальність в
у мене більше Нагадай мені також цей
21-річний хлопець і не хоче щоб його
впізнали є інтерсексуал він зробив
операцію тому що хотів мати чоловічі
статеві органи
кожного перерахунку 500 євро для мене це
половини річного заробітку за Тепер я
почуваю себе знову повноцінним зрештою Я
хочу одружитися і мати дітей а
а після операції мало інтерсексуалізм
здатні виробляти потомство для цих
чоловіків із сусіднього села це також
нічого б не змінило вони були проте Якби
хтось їхньої сім'ї одружися із
інтерсексуал
і хто знає Можливо в
А як почуваєтесь
знову погано я людина яка хоче любити
Але я хочу також коли бракує любові мені
стає погано
а потім і
о.в.
у але зіс ще не здався він хоче купити
собі дешевий телефон тому що в інтернеті
можна легко познайомитися із жінками У
крамниці де продають телефони Він
просить показати як можна сфотографувати
самого себе фотографія потрібно йому щоб
створити профіль коли він повертається
додому то знову трохи впевнені маленький
будинок зі своєю матір'ю та десятьма
іншими родичами мати ради що багато
років тому А зі вирішив бути чоловіком
чоловіка у нашому суспільстві більше
дівчина одружуються іде але чоловіки
можуть забезпечувати сім'ї успадковувати
усе ж
а а
А
то ж зі сподівається що колись за межами
його сила знайдеться жінка який не буде
заважати його минуле телефон він записує
пісню про кохання незабаром він
виставити її в интернет в
о.в.
у маленького
належить до Іспанії
іспанська традиції що купувалися
протягом століть
змагаються один з одним на переможця
очікують величезні призові гроші темні
щоб такого полювання цькування виживає
лише той хто швидше бігає інших собак
викидають над ними знущаються їх
убивають щороку така доля випадає
десяткам тисяч квартиру тому захисники
тварин вимагають припинити полювання
облави вони хочуть покласти кінець і
традиції
сьогодні вони можуть показати на що
здатні хорти так звані гальго які в
Іспанії полюють на зайців зі своїми
власниками Вони працюють поле на
околицях Мадрида один
починається
вони переслідують зайця зі швидкістю 75
км год перемагає той хто його спіймає
господар співак люблять Цей вид
полювання в А хто вчився що у своїх
предків
це пристрасть
змагань підходять лише молоді гальго так
як вона в
у цей гальго старший його просто
викинули знайшли захисники тварин і
віддали до тимчасового притулку
здогадується чому був залишений
напризволяще він більше не підходить для
змагань під час полювання на зайців лише
один випадок із багатьох
[музика]
повідомлень на вулиці або як у цьому
випадку в порожньому будинку їх
випробовують і якщо вони недостатньо
швидкий їх просто від сортової в
у
цьому притулку перебувають зараз 80-х
років більшість тварин уже
неприйнятна ситуацію тому він бореться в
об'єднанні проти полювання з гальго
проти розведенні Собаки проти того що
шанс отримують лише молоді та хороші
як ми поводимося нашій країні за
кордоном Я зустрічав людей Вони казали
цього викинули у вашій країні
у
Європейському Союзі полювання на зайців
заборонено але в Іспанії якщо живе цей
особливо пишається Абрахам кофра тому
він очолює організацію яка захищає
полювання сортами від усіх ризиків і
[музика]
а єдна захисників тварин але все це
величезна
поліцейських врятував багато
за його оцінкою цього року в Іспанії
кинули напризволяще занедбали або навіть
убили 50000 зворотній бік традиції тож
полювання
бізнесу
продається
хто заплатить за нього багато грошей і
люди які не займаються іншим крім
розведення щоб продавати в
і часто жорстокі бізнес
а усе контора зробив численні знімки
виснажених
злочин але не залишається зазвичай
жодних слідів
о.в.
у
тому що розрізали шиї вилучили
імплантований мікрочіп щоб не можна було
ідентифікувати власника він прив'язує
собаку на матусю дерева і Допобачення
зрозуміло Чому критика полювання на
зайців з картами стає все гострішою А
сам він такого б ніколи не зробив
говорить він і йому Шкода що деякі
господарі гальго прямують Імідж традиції
своїми з ними злочинами і
А
ще на початку хороша новина
інфікованих зменшується
ось сьомій годині ранку починається день
в інтернаті для сиріт акварель
[музика]
а
тут кожен знає що робити
[музика]
і
ті ж самі засоби
ті ж самі дози
вранці та ввечері в
у
Акварель це 40 хлопчиків і дівчаток від
чотирьох років до 17 плюси і мінуси
позитивних та негативних дітей
з
підлогою посуд замовчувалися у Великих
банках із великою кількістю
дезинфікуючих засобів було дуже важко
створити для них толерантне середовища
нам знадобилося шість років перш ніж усі
співробітники почали сприймати і
поважати це дітей і
а й Усі знають що у повсякденному житті
він позитивні не несуть навколишнім
ніякої небезпеки зараження навіть якщо
хтось
біля найменших дітей завжди є вихователь
старші знають що вірус нестійкий її не
відразу після того вступає у контакт з
повітрям у
А що це їхні діти
Акварелі вони ростуть у захищених умовах
ранок свідомо обходитися зі своєю
віл-інфекцію навіть краще ніж будь-який
дорослий
Було
одного разу Наші діти були у літньому
таборі першого вечора дітей Купали тут
обережна відчиняються двері й допитливо
заглядає начальник літнього табору наша
Хто наші діти мають можливо чотири вух
або дві голови
Олега питає мене Маріно що мені робити
нам привезли віл-інфікованого хлопчика
вона розгубилася чому річ кажу я
звичайно Хай грається з іншими і
в Акварелі Настав вечір і знову кожен
знає що робити ті ж самі засоби ті ж
самі дози в
а залишається лише хвилювання дорослих
за маленьких після того як вони вийдуть
із дитячого будинку через алкогольна або
наркотична залежність своїх матерів
багато мешканців притулку залишиться
інвалідами і відсталими у розвитку на
все своє життя єдина надія на те що
когось із них адаптують щоб не бути
самотнім упродовж усього свого життя
[музика]
У цьому розділі ми
а а
у нас робити коли засоби для існування
зникають
з того часу як запаси риби Середземного
моря різко скорочується і не іншому люди
перед узбережжям іскри беруть своє
майбутнє у власні руки і змінюють
професію замість ниток вони воліють
брати на борт туристів із ними виходять
на полювання за скарбами Італія має
надлишку
із риболовлі розповідає джуліо лауро
вони вже давно не можуть жити тож
рибалки і
влаштувалися під час сезону відпочинку
вони будять місцевістю туристів Поки що
все нормально але на цьому човні дещо
інакше власними руками вони будували
скляне Дно і пропонують екскурсії до
енергії у затонули минуле римлян на
острові iska новий культурний туризм на
і хочуть розвивати такі хлопці як син
Джулія Енн
в морі інакше ніж наші батьки
[музика]
І звісно залучили підводного археолога і
а
Підводна археологія є виснажливою
справою за короткий проміжок часу течія
та хвилі часто знову закривають те що
очищали сантиметр за сантиметром
але рибалки не здавалися навіть зробили
маленьке археологічне відкриття
Римського Гавань
колись вона могла мати Такий вигляд
тим часом досвідченими шукачами скарбів
але попри всю рутинну Тут набагато
більше ніж робота з
А я працюю водій кожний передання це
хвилююча подія
адже щоразу можна виявити щось нове
ознака того що колись було допомагає нам
зрозуміти минуле
кожен день приносить нові відкриття в
А я вже зараз живе виключно історизму
щороку на острів приїжджають сотні тисяч
відвідувачів
вони купаються у гарячих джерелах
відвідуються знаменитий арагонський
замок а іноді біля острова кидають Якір
своєї супер як ти
новий туристичний напрямок завжди
вітається каже міський голова але
фінансову підтримку рибалками Він
пообіцяв не хоче й
Ось і вони будуть продовжувати хоч і без
державної підтримки у цьому є і своя
перевага каже джуліо Таким чином ніхто
не може втрутитися в їхню роботу
аби прощаємося з наступного тижня це
була програма з Європи
Київ 2019 рік рік
о.в.